[Music]
so recently I've been doing a lot of
things which are very adult I gave it
headaches talk which will be available
at some point on the TEDx YouTube I'll
let you know when it is I handed in my
thesis which despite the fact that
that's basically what this channel has
been built on rightly I talk about my
degrees too much and most recently I am
moved house yesterday I got dropped off
by my dad very kindly in a big band and
I moved in with my best friend so yeah
sorry - pixel god I have got a house
together this is kind of a big scary
adult moment and I'm not quite sure how
I feel about being this this adulty
we've already unpacked the bedroom
everything's we built the bed pixel girl
built this set of drawers by herself
I told my mum that and she was just
immediately like marry her and then
there's a couple's relationship building
activity we built this IKEA wardrobe
together which was a five-hour fun
experience but now priority is getting
the computer up and running so I can get
back to work before that though all of
these have got to go up in the loft Oh
yummy to reach that expects a head of
bath to come out hello
okay there's a light search huh okay
should we put the boxes up here yeah
yeah it's pretty best there we go this
ethic reminds me it's penny time my dad
because we used to have mother away up
in our attic
it's feel like a very parenting thing to
be doing right now
The Loft is for parents
alright that's about it I know I wanted
to look like I liked you at what point
do you become an adult I've been
thinking about this you're older than me
now let's get busy get my office
together
alright that's a lot better
shop done Coke Zero obtained freezer
books we'll get to those and we are
moved in something that you realize I
think when you get older is that you
have always thought that people older
than you
whether that be a few years older than
you in school or your teachers if you're
a student or you know your boss
if you've got a job I think everyone
just kind of assumes that older people
have got - together these people know
what they're doing in life where they're
going they are adults Capital a adults
presumably some of you think this about
me and let me tell you despite the fact
that I've moved in with my girlfriend
and we've built IKEA furniture together
and we did our first grocery shop
together in the car at no point did a
little light bulb go on in my brain and
say you're an adult now son that's not
to say I still feel like a child
I definitely feel kind of grown-up but
no I don't feel the way I thought adults
felt when I was a kid does that mean I'm
not an adult bear with me I've got to go
somewhere
today I have gone full Casey nice tat
and I have been flown to Frankfurt for
just today I'm fine about this evening
to meet with the people the Central
European bank they have a pretty
phenomenal set of officers here
including some fantastic views from the
top I'm making some videos for the
Moffat's in two weeks I'm going to a
conference in Portugal and making some
videos about economics so apparently
they work sometimes here we've just been
having this meeting I'll let these two
continue for played we were just having
this meeting about the videos which I'm
going to be making as someone with no
knowledge of economics at all apparently
minute perfect to provide this lay
person's perspective as I'm coming in
talk to a bunch of PhD students about
their research in Wavell economics which
is going to be really fun
[Music]
all of these capital a adult things have
been happening to me but a no point has
somebody either recently over the past
couple of years tapped me on the
shoulder and said you would add up now
because that just doesn't happen a lot
it is defined by what you do not by a
tick box all right I think like so many
things in life I feel like we look for
an easy set of criteria like life is a
game you collect a certain number of
collectibles you could complete a
certain question and you are adult that
doesn't work at all it is defined by
what you do
I think at the end of the day a lot
ahead is difficult to define because
life is difficult to find it's messy it
means complete different things with
different people I guess that just
enough of the things I've always
associated with other had happened in
rapid succession recently which made me
think maybe maybe I am I'm an adult but
what I've come to realize is that more
than these things happening to me like
being flown out to Germany it's my
reaction to these what I think of as
adult things that actually determines
how adult I am and I think in how we've
moved house and how you know preparing
to give a talk in preparing to go and
meet with the Central European Bank I've
been acting as I think adults at tip and
I was a kid and I think now for the
first time in my life I've crossed over
into that boundary of feeling and being
I feel like a capital a adult and I
guess I just wanted to make a video
about that really also just to update
you on everything that's been happening
because it's been a little bit nuts that
TEDx talk in particular that will be
available like I said at the start on
the TEDx channel I will share it on my
community tab so make sure that you're
subscribed to the channel and you've
doing the notification bell because I
think you need to do that to get
notified when I like post something or
to see it in your feed so yeah I think
it's really interesting to look
obviously I'm biased but I would love
for you guys to see it and give me your
your thoughts on why I have to say on
that same trip up north I also filmed a
super interesting video which I can't
wait to edit on a really interesting
computer at the Museum of Science and
Industry in Manchester and yeah that's
gonna be coming out in a couple of weeks
also this month there's going to be some
stuff at the yogscast hopefully there's
gonna be some vlogs about pixel-by-pixel
colonize new life so all of this
traveling and the moving house kind of
explains why things have been a little
bit quiet on this channel I've also been
focusing away thesis Corrections which
I'm nearly done I've got to finish
writing them up so yeah this coming
month will be there'll be a lot more
stuff coming out on this channel than
the past month hopefully this should be
now the new normal and lots of videos
from interesting places on different
topics in science and also some vlogs
and a book video coming soon I promise
there's some I've been reading a lot
recently and
and keep to talk about it anyway this
has gone on too long thank you very much
for watching this video please do
comment with your definition of when you
think you became an adult or if you
didn't consider yourself an adult when
you think you will become an adult I
mean it's different for different people
perhaps I'm a particular late developer
but I want to know your thoughts my
favorite part about being a youtuber is
this interaction that we can have so
let's make the most of that please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
thank you again for watching do you like
the video if you enjoyed it and
definitely subscribe if you're not ready
because there's so many cool things
lined up this month it's I cannot wait
for you to see some of the stuff I'm
working on yeah okay this is gonna be
fun I'll see you the next one